affaire grégory jean-marie et christine
villemin à nouveau entendue aujourd'hui
par le juge simon à dijon au centre de
cette audition les cassettes
d'enregistrement du corbeau le compte
rendu de cette journée didier bouillon
cette audition de jean marie et
christine villemin et de leurs parents
avaient un but précis écoutez toutes les
cassettes des appels du corbeau
il y en a plusieurs dizaines mais parmi
elles deux revêtent une importance
particulière
la première vient d'être versée au
dossier par le père de jean marie albert
villemin lui-même une cassette d'un
appel enregistré quelques jours après le
crime dans lequel le corbeau affirme
avoir photographié la mort de l'enfant
mais était ce le vrai corbeau et quelle
valeur à cette cassette
la deuxième a déjà fait parler d'elle à
cause d'une voix d'enfant elle a déjà
été expertisées pour savoir si cette
voie passer ou non par la ligne
téléphonique la réponse affirmative des
experts constitué un élément à charge
contre christine villemin mais ses
doigts l'enfant est aussi l'objet d'une
polémique entre jean marie et ses
parents
les auditions de ces deux cassettes
auront sans doute été les temps forts de
cette journée mais pour compléter les
observations des deux inculpés et de
leur part partie civile le président
simon devra attendre les conclusions de
l'expert présents aujourd'hui qui aura
pour tâche si c'est possible de
déterminer si la voix du corbeau et
celle d'un homme ou celle d'une femme